نذهب الى الدوحه ومفرد العربيه ليس بساري
ليث اهلا بك معنا اليوم ليس هناك من
مباريات بالامس كان فوز لفرنسا ولكن كانت
تصفيق والتحيه اكثر يمكن
للمنتخب المغربي الاجواء اليوم ماذا عن
الجماهير المغربيه هل تركت الدوحه ام
ستنتظر لحضور المركز الثالث والرابع
هناك عائلات مغربيه غادرت الى مطار محمد
الخامس في كازابلانكا او في الدار البيضاء
والكثير بقى هنا يعني هنا عائله من
كازابلانكا من الدار البيضاء وهنا همم
فتيات يعني ابدا مع الفتيات اذا سمحت همم
اتينا من شيكاغو من امريكا وهي مغربيه
وتفضل ان تبقى هنا حتى النهايه حتى
التشجيع المنتخب المغربي يوم السبت الذي
سيواجه المنتخب الكرواتي همم
وليداته وغادي نبقاو معاهم حتى اخر لحظه
للمنتخب ديالنا همم وقطر تانكي سو ماتش
شكرا كثير قطر على نعم هذه السيده طبعا
اتت من المغرب من طنجه وهي طبعا قالت لن
اغادر قطر حتى اخر رمق للمنتخب هنا
المنتخب المغربي السلام عليكم همم طبعا
احنا همم جينا باش نشوفوا المنتخب ديالنا
المنتخب اللي اعطانا احلى من الكاس اللي
هي محبه الشعوب العربيه اللي شفناها
ولسناها في طرقات قطر شفنا كيف الفلسطيني
يجيء علينا كيف القطار يجي علينا كيف
الاردن كيف في المصري كل كل كل كل كل
العرب
هذا هذا شيء هذا شيء اكثر واكبر من كاس من
مجرد كاس هذا الحب هذا الشيء كبير كثير
والحمد لله فريقنا خلانا نعرف قيمتنا عند
الدول العربيه وعرفنا محبتنا قديش بقلبهم
وطبعا احنا معاهم للاخير ومش مطلوب منهم
يقدموا اكثر من اللي قدمه كفو
بالفعل ميسون الكثير من الجاهليه العربيه
المقيمين والذين اتوا اصبحوا جميعا مع
المنتخب المغربي يعني الكثير منهم كانوا
يشجع منتخبات اخرى قبل وصول المغرب او
المنتخب المغربي لهذه المرتبه ولكنهم
اليوم اصبحوا جميعا المغاربه تفضل انت
حضرتك من كذاب انت متى وصلت
يعني فريقنا ولو ان هناك هزيمه ولكنه
بالنسبه
البطوله تنتهي بعد انه يوم السبت يوم
بالنسبه لنا لانه بالمرتبه الثالثه ليس
بشيء همم يعني همم اليسير وان شاء الله
سوف
يقوم بما بما اتي من جهد وقوه للفوز ليضيف
المرتبه الثالثه عالميا
ويمثل الدول الافريقيه والعربيه المسلمه
ان شاء الله لانه بطوله العالم لم تنتهي
بعد انه البوديوم في ثلاث مراكز المركز
الاول والثاني والثالث
والماتش يعني المقابله ديال اليوم السبت
باذن
الله
وقتنا انتهى لهذه المقابله شكرا لك
ان يكون المنتخب المغربي في الاربعه او
الثالث همم
نهار السبت شكرا لك دائما كنت وافينا
بالاجواء الحاصله في هذا المونديال
العربيه ليت ري